a professor and Clinton labor secretary
robert rice lays out what he thinks has
gone wrong for ordinary citizens in the
United States arguing that our post-war
economic growth grew out of a social
contract that has collapsed over decades
of social Darwinism mr. rice presents a
prescription to reverse this trend
through progressive reform it's an hour
hi I'm Carla Cohen I'm one of the owners
of politics and prose and I want to
welcome you here this afternoon it's a
wonderful turnout for the afternoon and
bob was thanking me and I was saying no
I would like to take credit for it but
it's because of him and his following
and that he's talking about things that
we all care about and we're very very
happy to have the opportunity to hear
him in person so Robert rice well Carla
thank you so much I I don't know if you
have if you have any kind of a little
footstool or something I could stand on
or maybe what I'll do is just take these
out of their sockets could I do that and
I'll do one in each other one I i can be
ike ambidextrous how's that and i can
barely see all of you but thank you so
much for coming out in the afternoon
like this and i want to thank politics
and prose and thank Carla once again for
on very short notice really arranging
for me to be able to come and talk to
all of you and also to talk about a book
that is called I'll be short and it
refers to the length of the book and the
subtitle which is even more important is
essentials for a decent working society
I was compelled really I felt very
strongly about the importance of writing
this book and it's a it's more than a
compilation of past essays it's sort of
a I started putting together a past
essays beacon press asked me to do it
right after I decided to run for office
for
the governorship of Massachusetts and
beacon press came to me and asked me to
put together some of my essays and I
said sure and naively I said sure
because of course when you try to put
together essays and try to make them
coherent it necessitates a lot of extra
work because essays don't naturally fit
together if you want to make the whole
greater than some of the parts you've
got to actually do a lot of additional
writing and think about how the essays
fit together and sometimes when you
write essays they fit together obviously
and beautifully but sometimes essays
actually are sort of stopping places
along an intellectual journey of several
years and it turns out that it is
fascinating to go back and see where you
have been over those few years in this
case it was mostly the years 1999 2000
2001 and also the start just the start
of 2002 quite important years in terms
of this country because at the start of
this period of time we thought that the
we knew no bounds we thought at the
start of this period 1999 to 2002 that
it was possible for anybody to make it
and not just make it in this country but
make it in a very big way young people
coming out of college thought that they
could be almost instantaneously wealthy
beyond anybody's dreams we had
advertisements for people if they just
simply invested in the stock market
truck drivers could have their own South
Sea Islands it was possible for us to
get rich quick and not really make
enormous effort in the process but there
was something else about these years we
as America we as Americans were at the
top of the heap we were impregnable we
were the most dominant without any doubt
we had achieved economic dominance and
political dominance and we were supreme
in every conceivable way so you had this
almost distillation of time historians
will look back on these years and say
what naivete
what extraordinary misleading exuberance
it wasn't just irrational exuberance in
the stock market it was a kind of
irrational exuberance about our own
efforts as individuals not as members of
a society because there was very little
discussion of this public good or what
was socially good or the public interest
it was the notion that we as individuals
could extend the range of our riches our
ambitions beyond belief the world was to
use the old phrase our oyster
globalization was almost necessarily now
granted there was upon opposing view but
the dominant view as globalization was
good for all of us free markets were
good for all of us and we were a bunch
of individuals out to conquer the world
for ourselves or to put the matter
another way rational self interests The
Economist's golden rule was we thought
during these years justified as being
ultimately in everyone's interests now
what we forgot was several things which
we then learned with a thud one was that
markets don't always go up that the
stock market can go down very easily the
proponents of privatization with regard
to social security are still believe it
or not still talking about privatizing
social security but the the excitement
in the idea of privatization the
excitement and idea that everybody could
own a share of a stock has kind of gone
out of it as the balloon popped as we
knew some of us knew it would the
question was when irrational exuberance
could not last forever there's something
naive and quickly naive about that
notion of individual privatized wealth
through simply calling your stockbroker
or getting on on etrade or doing
whatever you're going to do as your own
individual trader there was something
also naive and
sadly poignant ly naive about the notion
that we as Americans were impregnable
that we were on top of the heap in terms
of the international global economy and
also in terms of politics nothing could
hold us back we ruled the world and
obviously after September 11th that
particular view seems humbling seems
dangerously naive this afternoon we hear
about somebody preparing a dirty bomb
how easy it is and how easy it suddenly
appears for almost anybody to get the
ingredients together to cause massive
destruction and although many of us
rationally knew this to be possible
before September 11th in the exuberance
of 19 99 and 2000 2001 frankly none of
us really paid very much attention there
was also an exuberance about the
corporation the American corporation the
idea that somehow executive salaries
although they were through the
stratosphere were justified because
American executives were doing such a
fabulous job adding value to their
companies and we saw these American
companies doing so well that nobody
wanted to really sound the alarm about
executive salaries the chief executives
of American companies yes they were
criticized here and there but they were
the heroes of the new economy they were
blazing the trail to riches for this new
class of shareholder most of us about
half american adults became shareholders
it was a wonderful blissful era for
celebrating the modern corporation and
then Enron and then the re-emergence of
the understanding that greed can work
not only not only to the benefit of
people at the top and to the detriment
of employees but also to the detriment
of shareholders there was
a natural and inevitable linkage between
how well the top executives did even
though their compensation depended on
share values and how well shareholders
were doing it was possible to fake the
books who was looking after the people
who were supposed to be looking after
the people who were supposed to be
paying attention who was really running
the show now in all of these respects
its irrational exuberance in the stock
market the notion that we were
impregnable in terms of international
diplomacy and politics and governance
the notion that our CEOs and our great
corporations were basically understood
something that they had not understood
for years they understood how to
generate huge value enormous value use
technology add to our nation's wealth
that they were doing a wonderful job and
could not be criticized all of these
notions now seem quite suddenly to be
called into question now in my book I
talk about something that may to our
modern ears seem very coins I use the
term social contract because every
country every society does have a social
contract it's not written down usually
entirely in law or entirely in
constitutional provision often it is in
norms or in values in assumptions that
we share together and the point that I
make in the book is that in the 1950s
and 60s and even right through the 1970s
there was in the United States something
of the emergence of a social contract
about certain basic ideas and those
basic ideas this is before the era that
I've just been talking about this is
before the era of irrational exuberance
and the celebration of the individual
and the new Gilded Age before that in
the 1950s 60s and 1970s emerged in the
United States a set of ideas about what
we owed one another
as members of the same society those
ideals that social contract standard
very much on work now I don't want to
romanticize or glorify this era there
was still plenty wrong there was still a
lot and there is still a lot of racism
they were still and is still a lot of
homophobia there was and is still a lot
of gender ism and sexism in our society
I don't want to romanticize the years
but I do want to emphasize that there
were three provisions of a rudimentary
social contract that whether you called
yourself a liberal or a conservative or
a Republican or a Democrat or really
regardless of what label you put on your
ideology most people subscribe to these
three provisions provision number one
was if your corporation the business you
were working for it did better if it was
profitable you would have job security
now in times of a downturn in the
business cycle you may lose your job
temporarily that was called a layoff but
you would get your job back again that's
why we called it lay off you would get
back on again and you would have
unemployment insurance during that
interval and if your company did better
and better if the profits except on
going up then you as an employee would
not only have job security you would
also have a better paycheck and you
would have increasingly health care and
also a pension a defined benefit pension
plan at the end not everybody had all of
this but that was the aspiration to
which we were moving as a society we
simply assumed as part of a social
contract that if companies were okay and
profitable you'd have job security if
they did better and better employees
would not only have security they also
would do better and better and they
would not do only to better and better
salary but also with regard to as I said
health care and pension protection an
aspiration a social contract aspiration
provision number two of that mid-century
social contract was that if you worked
hard and if you had a full-time job you
would not
in poverty now again there were
exceptions but the aspiration and the
assumption was anybody who's a full-time
worker not only will will that person
not be in poverty but also the family of
that part Trump that full-time worker
will not be in poverty and if it should
happen that you due to sickness or
disease or death in the family or
whatever hardship whatever misfortune
occurred if you could not have a
full-time wage earner in the family then
there would be social insurance to cover
you and that began in the 1930s in terms
of Social Security and right up through
1965 and Medicare we never had an entire
cradle to grave social democratic system
like Europe we didn't want that we
simply wanted something that was premise
on work as I said provision number two
of the social contract was if you had a
full-time job you and your family would
not be in poverty and also if you got
knocked out of a full time job or could
not have a full-time job there would be
social insurance to keep you going
provision number three and the final
provision of the United States social
contract mid-century based on work again
was that everyone should have an
opportunity to make the most of their
god-given talents and abilities and that
was not only with regard through K
through 12 education and we desegregated
we certainly do jet segregated with
regard to desirae legalized segregation
but we also at least made some attempts
to start the process of desegregating
with regard to Geographic and de facto
segregation we also launched in the
1950s and 1960s increasingly a public
publicly underwritten system of public
higher education one of the most
ambitious programs in the history of
this country every stage enlarged its
public higher education its state
universities its state colleges its
community colleges again the principle
being that every child regardless
their background if they graduated high
school they should at least have an
opportunity to go to college Pell Grants
many of you remember Pell grants the
Pell Grant program expanded students
could go without generating huge huge
lending obligations the aspiration of
the social contract was everyone should
have an opportunity to make the most of
their god-given talents and abilities
now I talked about the social contract
because it seems to me it's very
important to understand what happened to
it during the period of the second
guilded age and let's talk about that as
basically the late 80s and 90s and right
on through the current comeuppance if
you want to call it that or at least the
the shock that we've all had with regard
to the stock market and Enron and 911
what happened to that mid century social
contract and the aspirations surrounding
that contract is a fundamental dis these
basic precepts with regards to the first
precept that corporations as they did
better their workers should do better
well by the 1980s as corporate raiders
took over corporations as the cuz the
structure of the economy shifted so
there was much more intense competition
companies no longer thought and saw
themselves as representing all of the
stakeholders their communities their
employees and others they saw themselves
increasingly as representing only their
investors and the goal explicitly stated
was to maximize shareholder value even
if that meant laying off workers when
the companies were doing very profitably
even if that meant cutting back salaries
even if that meant cutting health
insurance and cutting back pension
protection or moving people from defined
benefit pensions to defined contribution
pensions which ultimately meant less and
less contribution by the employer the
goal was to make a profit for the
shareholders
and CEO compensation increasingly became
connected to directly connected to how
the shareholders were doing now we
thought that that was understandable it
was justifiable and indeed many people
argue even today that that was the
engine by which we became more quote
unquote competitive our old companies
that were having a very hard time by the
1980s competing with the Japanese and
increasingly with the Germans our
companies were transformed into power
houses and the justification was that
once we shifted from a view of corporate
responsibility that embraced all
shareholders and also employees and also
communities to one that just maximize
shareholder returns it made companies
more efficient it locked them into
efficiency it forced them to be
innovative now the fact that social
Darwinism was in the background the fact
that much of our language shifted from
the common good or public interest to
simply maximizing individual well-being
was thought to be a kind of necessary
byproduct to the public discussion a
kind of a an incidental by-product to
the way we re envisioned the role of the
corporation and they indeed the process
of the economy inequality began to widen
very very dramatically in the 1970s in a
clouded quality widened again in the
1980s and continued to widen through
most of the 1990s but again we tended
not to pay a great deal of attention we
looked at our companies becoming more
innovative we looked at the economy
overall as generating a lot of new added
value and it seemed to us basically
worth the cost and with regard to the
second provision the provision that said
any person who is working full-time
should have a certainly not being
poverty we saw male wages ma le the
wages of men continue to decline
beginning in the late 1970s unions were
assaulted
attacked unionization declined
dramatically in 1955 about thirty five
percent of our private sector workers
were unionized enough to set prevailing
wages by the 1990s by the mid-1990s that
was fewer than ten percent of our
private sector workers were unionized we
embraced globalization and again did it
I think understanding that there may be
winners and losers in the process but
the winners came out so much further
ahead they could compensate the losers
and still come out ahead and we also
finally in 1996 got rid of welfare and
we said that may be tough love but
people will be better off off welfare
and with a job even if some of them end
up in poverty well the fact of the
matter is that welfare rolls did decline
and that probably was a good thing but
we also ended up with at the end of the
1990s and we certainly have and this was
even before the recession a larger and
larger population of people who we might
call working poor that used to be an
oxymoron working poor a lot of people
went from welfare into work but it was
work that would not pay enough to
support their family male wages
continued to decline women poured into
the workforce beginning of the late
seventies and right through the 1980s
and 1990s I wish I could say that women
went to work largely because of
wonderful new opportunities open to
professional women well that was partly
the case but most women flooded into the
workplace in the 1970s certainly in the
1980s and 1990s largely because they
needed to work in order to prop up
family incomes because male wages were
dropping and as we began to get rid of
social insurance and it wasn't only
unemployment it wasn't only welfare it
was also unemployment insurance at the
start of this era if you were unemployed
if you were laid off you would get
unemployment insurance but by the
mid-1990s late 1990s most people who
were laid off most people
didn't have a job temporarily were not
eligible for unemployment insurance
states kept on constricting eligibility
for unemployment insurance and more and
more workers were working part-time and
they were working as contract workers or
they were women who were working at
minimum wages they simply did not
qualify for unemployment insurance so
again another piece of that social
insurance that social fabric another
piece of that what we took for granted
to be the social contract came undone
and third and finally education the
assumption that anybody should be able
to make the most of their god-given
talents and abilities by the 1990s we
began to see a pattern emerging and that
pattern was that if you were wealthy you
tended to live in a wealthy neighborhood
your tax base could support a very good
school or you sent your children to
private school if you were poor you
tended to live in a poor town or a poor
city geographic concentration of wealth
and poverty intensified and that meant
that the tax bases were entirely
different supporting schools we tried to
begin to rectify that constitutionally
in certain states but we have a long way
to go and meanwhile meanwhile state
supported higher education found itself
in state after state with budgets cut
and instead of there being a lot of
federal pell grant money on a lot of
opportunities for young people to go to
college it turns out that right now the
average working class child instead of
relying on sixty percent funding that is
grant and forty percent loan for college
it's just the reverse right now it is
sixty percent loan forty percent grant
many of our middle class and our
working-class children and certainly our
poor children they are if they do go to
higher education they are ending their
years with huge debt and many of them
simply cannot afford college to begin
with what happened to the social
contract why did it disintegrate in so
many respects
well I don't want to give away the punch
line because if I give it away you will
not necessarily go to the trouble of
getting the book but let me just give
you some hints along the way and I don't
want this to be a gloom and doom
discussion or gloom and doom lecture
because I am actually quite upbeat about
the recreation of a social contract in
the future but let me just say that part
of any social contract depends upon a
sense that there but for the grace of
God go I that we are all in the same
boat together when we use vocabulary
like the public interest or the common
good or the Commonwealth many of our
state's some of our states were called
Commonwealth's like Massachusetts
Commonwealth a very old term when we use
those expressions we mean that the
public good the sense of success of a
society is measured not just in terms of
individual wealth its measured in terms
of our collective well-being and when we
understand there but for the grace of
God go I anybody who is less fortunate
could be me I could be the one to have
lost my job I could be the one to
suddenly need health insurance I could
be the one to need unemployment
insurance I could be the one who needs a
good education or my children could be
the ones who need a good publicly
supported system of higher education
we're all in the same boat and I and
they could be the together where do you
get that sense of there but for the
grace of God go I we get that sense
partly because we face a common peril
and this country in the 1930s starting
with the depression and going through
the Second World War and through the
Cold War did face a common peril we
understood that we were in many respects
in the same boat together if we didn't
work together if we didn't understand
that we were all bound together in the
same society we would be in trouble out
of the common experience of the
Depression and World War two and the
Cold War we understood our commonality
but let me venture to say that after the
Cold War
and certainly after that danger receded
after the sense of either depression or
hot water cold war was no longer with us
that sense of commonality began to erode
it was more fashionable and easier
understood to think of us as separate
individuals each of us on our own and as
the gap between the wealthy and the poor
continued to widen it was harder and
harder for people who are on the top or
even than the top 20% to say there but
for the grace of God go I because they
knew in their heart of hearts that they
and their children would probably not be
on the losing side of whatever
transaction whatever unfortunate thing
conspired they and their children would
probably be on the winning side a
society that gets to splits between
winners and losers lose is fundamentally
a sense of Coast social cohesion because
the winners no longer empathize with the
losers they no longer see the losers as
themselves or potentially themselves
they see the losers as either racially
distinct or ethnically distinct or
simply people who have of so
fundamentally a different cultural set
of values that they and I we and they
are forever different we are not in the
same boat now what about the future
could it be that what has happened to us
over the past couple of years and see
indeed over the last year with regard to
911 and Enron the undermining of
confidence with regard to us being
necessarily involve all the undermining
of confidence with regard to our economy
and some of the large corporations and
even the conventions of capitalism that
we thought were were absolutely reliable
accounting balance sheets could it be
and is it possible that we can once
again craft
a sense of commonality could it be is it
possible that we can once again have a
discussion a serious discussion about
what we owe one another as members of
the same society not that we have no
responsibilities to anyone else around
the world but that as members of the
same society who need to be strong as a
society there may be the beginnings at
least of a conversation about a new
social contract we are in the same boat
together not only with regard to
international terrorism but also with
regard to needing and relying upon an
economy whose rules must be shaped in a
way that enables all of us to rely and
predict how corporations are going to
behave rules that enable all of us if we
work hard to rely on the fact that we
have some modicum of economic security
rules that enable us to live in a way
because our neighbors and our friends
and everybody else in our society also
lives in a way that celebrates and
respects human dignity now let me just
end this by saying that I am very upbeat
and I am very optimistic about the
beginnings of that new kind of
conversation those cynics and there are
many many cynics when it comes to using
the terms public interest and common
good and all of those rather quaint
terms there are a lot of there's it's
greeted by almost universal cynicism but
those cynics fail to see as I have in
fact I as I've gone around the state of
Massachusetts I'm now a candidate for
governor of Massachusetts talk about a
rash decision
how many of you by the way are from
Massachusetts I love you how many of you
know somebody who lives in Massachusetts
please talk to them tonight or tomorrow
politics it seems to me must not be
something that we sort of hold it arms
lengthen and hold our noses at the same
time politics is the applied form of
democracy if we reject politics if we
are fundamentally cynical about politics
to the point where we and our children
reject it then we are seeding the
terrain to people who are in it for the
wrong reasons it is vitally important
that part of this process of reinventing
the social contract entail an activism a
new activism in politics on behalf of
all of us now I am not suggesting that
all of you take the raft step that I did
and run for governor or run for up but
you may want to run for your local some
local office but you may want to get
more active in politics in some other
way you may want to assert leadership in
your community in some way we are all
very busy believe me it is not easy this
process but I think part of the process
of civic renewal and the renewal of a
social contract in these far more
fragile and perilous times entails
taking politics seriously in terms of
our personal lives not just a pastime
that's interesting to read about or
watch or be a kind of a voyeur and let
me end my presentation by just inviting
all of you to be leaders and by leaders
I mean simply this my definition of
leadership and I developed this a little
bit in the book leadership is not a
matter of holding officially a high
office you can be a leader without very
much formal Authority in fact you need
in your communities in your
organization's in your place
work you need to be leaders leadership
entails focusing the attention of people
around you on issues that they would
rather not see they would rather not
focus on there is so much escapism there
is so much denial going on leadership is
saying hey don't deny there are homeless
people out there on the streets don't
pretend they don't exist what are we
going to do about it leadership is a
matter of saying to whoever is around
you in whatever community or
organization you exist in we have
problems that need to be addressed and
let's begin to address them leadership
is the process of helping people fight
denial and escapism and the worst
feature which is resignation cynical
resignation that nothing really can
change cynical resignation that the
world and our institutions and our
politics and our communities and our
corporations are going to inevitably be
that way and there's nothing that can be
done to change them resignation is the
worst enemy of social change denial and
escapism are bad but resignation is the
worst you can be a leader by fighting
all of these and I invite you into the
world of leadership thank you all
and now thank you let me take any
questions you have and what I'll do is
repeat the question because we don't
have a microphone available to use I
will I will simply repeat the question
that you asked still stand up you can
still stand up oh I'm sorry professor
Wright in a period since the Second
World War when Western Europe seems
mainly to have embraced the social
contract why have we turned in the
opposite direction the question is in
the period since the Second World War
when Western Europe seems to have
embraced a social contract why have we
turned in the opposite direction well as
I said I think up until the 60s and 70s
we did form a different kind of social
contract unlike the Social Democratic
social contract of Western Europe ours
was a somewhat more conservative social
contract based and premise Thanh work
and the obligation to work and it was
uniquely American we cannot simply take
Europe's social contract every society
has its own social contract in ours is
frankly and has always been more
conservative than the European certainly
the Social Democratic European contract
Europe is rapidly by the way moving in
the direction of the American revised
social contract that is the European
corporations are rapidly becoming just
like American corporations in fact there
is becoming no difference between
European and American corporations a CEO
salaries are going up a wage security
and job security is going down companies
are having less and less and taking less
and less responsibility for their
employees but there is still a sense
with regard to health care and education
that the bottom half will be brought up
to a relatively high minimum level lest
we fall too much enamored of the
European model however beware those
societies are much more homogeneous than
us than ours and also when it comes to
dealing with immigrants who are
different
likely they are not much better than us
in fact arguably they are far worse yes
sir I thought well the most startling
things you said was a declining union
membership was that thirty five to ten
percent why and what do you see about
the future of them the gentleman asks
what about union membership the decline
from the mid-50s from thirty-five
percent enough to set prevailing wages
in many industries down to in the
private sector fewer than ten percent of
workers unionized why did that happen
what happened for two reasons primarily
one because the unionized sector of our
economy tended to be manufacturing and
tended to be large manufacturing
businesses and the economy has in terms
of its structure shifted from
manufacturing to services and there are
many many more small businesses and most
of the job growth has been in smaller
businesses they are harder to unionize
they are more they demand not so much
routine work that can easily relented
self to job classifications and work
rules of a union variety but they tend
to lend themselves to a very different
kind of work environment but there's
something else going on and that is
beginning in the 1980s as corporate
raiders took over many many American
corporations as institutional investors
became much more demanding a performance
and as competition intensified not only
global competition but also domestic
competition it became harder and harder
for managers to avoid the temptation
let's put it in the nicest way I can
harder and harder for CEOs to avoid the
temptation of fighting their unions
fighting wage increases fighting
unionization itself illegally and I
remember as Secretary of Labor being
struck by the data that I was seeing in
the mid-1990s illegally preventing
people or penalizing workers who wanted
to form unions illegal under the law but
nevertheless the National Labor
Relations Board could do very
little worse than simply tap a company
on its figurative hand and say well you
have to provide back wages to that
particular worker and yet there were so
many instances and such a backlog that
many companies felt it was worth the
risk and also replacing striking workers
or threatening to replace striking
workers something that was perfectly
legal but not part of the social
contract not accepted to threaten the
replacement of striking workers but that
became increasingly common again as
competition intensified as businesses
and CEOs felt under pressure to keep
costs down and fight unions the future
of unions I think certainly in the local
service economy hotels hospitals retail
some large retail stores you see unions
doing fairly well because they are not
prone to the same kind of national or
international competition that you have
in manufacturing but it's going to be
hard for unions the fastest-growing
unions such as the Service Employees
International Union or apps me a public
employee unions well those are not the
same thing they are they are different
from the old unions I think we may see
and we are saying some evidence of
professionals beginning to unionize for
example airline pilots they've been
unionized for some time professors can
you imagine assistant professors others
beginning to unionize maybe not in the
same ways in which manufacturing workers
unionize but certainly unionize in order
to heighten their bargaining leverage
and their voice in institutions that
otherwise might not pay attention yes
he's like a look extreme wealth buying
stream influence and extreme influence
buying more wealth for the same yo top
one or
% of the population and you seem like
that's what's going on and that defeats
everything you're talking about well the
question is a good question i'll repeat
it how do we break the cycle of extreme
wealth buying extreme influence
corrupting the political process and
enhancing the extreme wealth that was
already there to begin with and by the
very nature of that process a
disenfranchising more and more of the
population who become cynical and say
why bother getting involved in politics
because basically the system is rigged
that's not exactly your question but
that's the question all except I think
the way to break that cycle is exactly
through the kind of grassroots politics
of engagement that I'm now talking about
you see this isn't the first time this
has happened in the united states in the
Gilded Age after the Gilded Age we did
have a Progressive Era beginning with
Teddy Roosevelt now Teddy resident have
described himself quite in progressive
terms Norwood Woodrow Wilson but that
era was characterized by some
extraordinary citizen involvement on the
state level that did bubble up to the
federal level in terms of eventually
unemployment insurance and minimum wages
and also antitrust Pure Food and Drug
legislation a progressive income tax and
then you see the same thing occurring or
at least reoccurring after the excesses
of the 1920s once we go into a
depression we have a new deal in which a
lot of legislation is premise Thanh the
notion that we really are in this
together we have to fight the forces not
so much the forces of malevolent
although there was some discussion about
malevolent leadership on the corporate
side but basically we're all in this
together because if we don't provide
social insurance for ourselves if we
don't provide the kind of public
investment that undergirds and must
undergird capitalism capitalism may
simply not survive we saw a little bit
of the shades of this in the 1960s again
with regard to Medicare but i think we
are on the cusp once again
of a citizen movement a political
movement to in a way save capitalism
from itself save capitalism from its
excesses and reassert the common good I
say this now you're smiling in cynicism
I can see a cynical smile whenever I
behold a cynical smile but let me let me
let me just tell you that after spending
the last six months campaigning around a
state that granted you is not typical of
every state in the Union but
Massachusetts has a reputation being a
very liberal state but the people in
Massachusetts actually are i would say
represent in terms of their own
conversations about their lives and what
they need a fairly good cross-section of
america nobody wants to pay more taxes
everybody but wants better services
people are also deeply concerned about
their own job security and also a game
that seems increasingly to be rigged in
a variety of ways they want a government
that is responsible to them not a
government riddled with nepotism and
patronage and they want companies that
really are there for their communities
and employees not simply for
shareholders and if they're there for
shareholders they want them to really be
there for shareholders and not just for
the top companies that may be
headquartered outside the state these i
want to emphasize with you are values
that don't go under the headings liberal
or conservative Republican or Democrat
this sense that we have somehow and it's
necessary to reassert the common good
against greed and social Darwinism for
one of a better term is very broadly
held the sense that we want a politics
of integrity we want people in politics
who aren't fakes Oh aren't phonies who
say what they believe who believe what
they say or dedicated to doing something
and we want more much more grassroots
politics we want a politics that in fact
is engaging and involving and
encompassing and inclusive this
is very basic to the American public
today and the Republicans if they were
wise they would latch on to these
sentiments just as there were Democrats
if they were wise would latch on to
these sentiments there is a public
spiritedness out there for the taking
now it needs to be coaxed some of it is
met with the same cynical smile you have
on your face but it is there and it is
there also in young people part of the
wonderful aspect of this story that I'm
telling you i spent have spent half of
my adult life in the public sector but
the other half of my adult life I have
spent as a university teacher a
professor and I can tell you I've seen a
big change over the last 20 years
undergraduates over the last couple of
years increasingly and this year marking
even a greater to a greater extent they
are taking public service very seriously
they're getting involved in their
communities they're doing more volunteer
work they're more interested in going
into professions like teaching instead
of investment banking now that could be
because you can't make money in
investment banking any longer but I do
believe that there and you can't make
certainly can make many money on
teaching but I do believe that there is
something new going on and I can see it
among among the young yes how do you
reconcile the the integrity that's
required of leadership with the the
partisan of the petty partisan politics
that you'll be forced to confront if you
become governor of Massachusetts the
question is how do i reconcile the need
and desire among the public for
integrity with the petty partisan
politics that is our political culture
and that I will have to engage in you
say if I become governor of
Massachusetts it's your guess you're
cynical yes I I would say that and here
again i want to point to some pieces of
evidence i think that the public deeply
longs for a politics of integrity and is
turned off by partisanship
and certainly turned off by negative
advertising turned off by mudslinging we
went through it in the 1990s at the
national level with Republicans and
Democrats here in Congress and at the
end of it I think nobody looked good and
the public right now again I think this
is partly post-911 and partly post Enron
and partly a sense that we need a
different kind of politic the public is
even more insistent upon a politics of
integrity than before and the public
will I believe now maybe this is maybe
maybe not immediately maybe this is my
maybe it'll happen if not this year next
year the year after the public will
award politicians who demonstrate
integrity who demonstrate that they are
going to take the high road and stay on
the high road and that they believe they
have fundamental beliefs that they have
passionate beliefs that are hopefully in
accord with what the constituents of
their constituents also believe there's
a greater premium now I believe placed
on integrity then has been in years yes
ma'am what frightens me is a whole
segment of the independent voter and the
so-called independent thinker in this
country
concerning themselves more with things
that are happening in other countries
rather than working to improve our
country you have to address that do you
have to address these people because
they are on the fringe of going the
wrong way let me repeat the question I
want to make sure I understood the
question the question is what do you do
about the so-called independent thinkers
the intellectual elites would you
include them no no those who consider
themselves not a Democrat the
independents who are neither democrat or
republican who are increasingly in your
words concerned about what happens in
the rest of the world but seem to be
less concerned about what's happening in
their own backyards and I'm not sure
exactly to whom you are referring my
experience is that there is increasingly
and again i'm referring to my students
and many people i meet across the state
of massachusetts and when i was Labor
Secretary may be many ordinary working
Americans who I would come across there
is a sense that we are bound in a global
economy that it is an integrated and
interdependent global economy we can't
simply put up the gates some people
would like to put up gates but we must
understand that what happens around the
rest of the world affects us and if
there was any doubt about that before
nine eleven there certainly is no doubt
about that now now I grant you that some
people would like to say let's isolate
ourselves let's just simply break off in
the rest of the world but i think that
is less even less realistic now than it
was before there are some people who
would like to say let's fight terrorism
but let's not fight also the causes of
terrorism or the terrain in which
terrorism can take seed but but i think
it's very important for all of us while
we are concerned about the social
contract in America to also take
cognizance of the fact that terrorism
while it has to be fought strongly and
valiantly and toughly must also we must
also be responsible in the world that
poverty and hunger
and disease and vast populations who are
illiterate and barely holding on and the
extraordinary infant mortality we find
in sub-saharan Africa and also in South
Asia that these while not directly
responsible for terrorism are
nonetheless the environments in which
anti-americanism and terrorism can
thrive our own interest if not an
international moral concern our own
interests with demand we respond to
these but that's not inconsistent with
our own social contract I think that I
think it's quite consistent with it we
have time for a couple more questions so
let's take two more questions yes I
wonder if we can continue to talk about
common good
have to confess and simple
and just consider
instead of expanding this world because
I did
the column that their flag let's take
education we can neglect education in
this country because we can all kiss in
car
in the cards who have been educated in
another country we don't have to spend
planet
well let me let me repeat yes let me
repeat the question and it's a variant
actually on the preceding question and
the question is why shouldn't we and I'm
going to state in a slightly different
way but why should isn't it important as
a ground rule the kind of prerequisite
for any discussion of the social
contract of the common good to limit it
in some ways to the United States
because if we don't limit it to the
United States it is so easy for those of
us who are more fortunate to simply
import what we need by way of human
capital talented people from the rest of
the world resources from the rest of the
world it is very easy for those who are
on the winning side of the divide here
in the United States to simply divorce
themselves from the losers and become
global citizens rather than citizens of
America I want it once again emphasize
something and I'm going to restate my
answer in a slightly different way to
your question in order for us to be
world citizens in any meaningful sense
and most of you here understand what i
mean by that that would entail debt
forgiveness for many countries that are
under the extraordinary yoke of debts
that go back sometimes decades it would
entail foreign aid that was directly
directly and meaningfully attached to
education and health care it would
entail helping governments develop their
own middle classes reducing child
poverty and so forth in order to do that
in order to develop the public support
in this country for that we have to have
a very strong and confident middle class
once again in other words it is
difficult politically for us to do any
of that if we in the United States don't
feel secure economically if so many of
our citizens feel that the game is
rigged here we don't have the confidence
that we need to be good global citizens
public citizenship here in America a
social contract here is in some senses
not all senses but in
senses a political prerequisite to being
a good global citizen politically it's
hard to build the will unless we in our
own backyards develop strong social
bonds it's not one or the other and we
have time for one more question yes sir
say what comments you can make about the
general corruption in both politics and
in the private sector you feel that we
have a greater tolerance for corruption
then the public used to have when you
consider only the purchase of Congress
of politicians through campaign
contributions and by other means you see
this related to the corruption you see
in the end Ron's and there are many more
than the end runs I really just use that
as an illustration but there many more
and that as well as in the the
falsification of advice by stockbrokers
how do you see I have the kind of feel
that that we've been
in see increasing corruption throughout
the whole society where there comes from
television and poor taste there's been a
decline and I like and I would vote for
optimistic politicians let me let me if
I may repeat your question and also
respond to it and this will be our last
our last question the quittin it's a
very good question because you use a
term that I did not use and I will use
it because you used it and the term is
corruption and the question is have we
become more tolerant as a society of
corruption both in the political and
public sphere and also in the private
corporate sphere are we simply willing
to tolerate it has the threshold level
of public tolerance continued to drop
and are we now seeing it as a result all
over the place I think we were more
tolerant of what you term corruption in
the good years particularly in the 1990s
when we ourselves felt that everything
was going very very well when the stock
market was on an upswing and let's face
it through most of the 80s and 90s with
that little correction quite large
correction 1987 we did have a stock
market that very well when we felt that
we were optimistic and we had every
reason to be optimistic as a nation
particularly after the fall of the
Soviet Union I think that we relaxed
somewhat our vigilance as long as the
economy was growing as long as we sort
of assumed that we had a good chance of
making it in a big way or our children
had a great chance of making it we sort
of shrugged our shoulders and said all
right the system is a little corrupt but
a little corruption so what we did let
down our vigilance we didn't see the
downside of corruption not only the
demoralization that would create but
also the fundamental inefficiencies and
lack of confidence and distrust that
option would generate in the public and
again we're talking about the public
sector the buying of Congress the
extraordinary money in politics and also
the private sector corruption which
we've just seen i'm using Enron and
global crossing and all of these as
simply symbols but you know it's spreads
far beyond those individual companies
part of reasserting a social contract is
reasserting that we will not tolerate
that kind of corruption and you reassert
it not just through laws and regulations
laws and regulations only take you so
far if there is not a strong social norm
that condemns your word corruption then
people who are corrupt or who feel that
society fundamentally will forgive will
find a ways around to circumvent
whatever laws there are the norm must
change society's willingness to accept
certain behaviors must alter we must say
to ourselves and I think again if you
looked at the Progressive Era the first
decades of the 20th century or you
looked at the kinds of changes wrought
during the 1930s and 40s certainly when
we faced the Second World War you saw a
society that became less tolerance of
self-dealing a society that said in
effect there is a powerful social and
public interest a common good and
somebody who is pocketing money or
somebody who is acting in ways that are
contrary to the public interest because
the public interest means something it
has constant and powerful meaning for
somebody was acting contrary to public
enters for personal gain that person
will be condemned and stigmatized not
just put to prison not just penalized
not just fine but fundamentally shamed
in society and that I think is part of
the revival we saw in the Progressive
Era the revival we saw
of civic pneus during the 30s and 40s
and part of the revival that we will see
over the next 10 years we had by
coincidence Ayla Roosevelt's but okay
with her before well there were
different party Roosevelt's yes where is
the next Roosevelt coming from here he
is no no no I don't I don't know i I
don't know and I don't and again going
back to my and let's really make this
the last the last point going back to my
point about civic engagement and
leadership it may not be that that that
this is a matter of of a messiah type
person or or a a messianic president I
think that it's more realistic to think
of this as a social movement a change in
consciousness so that many more people
assume personal responsibility for their
communities and for making sure that the
social contract works yes political
leaders will emerge business leaders
will emerge community leaders will
emerge but fundamentally it's a matter
of all of us taking more personal
responsibility thank you all
Robert rice is currently a democratic
candidate for governor of Massachusetts
his books include locked in the cabinet
the future of success and the work of
Nations his latest I'll be short
essentials for a decent working society
is published by beacon press on the web
at Beacon org